i i started acting doing improvisation
yeah
i used to have this saying when i was
doing improv he said when you're in your
head you're dead
you know so i feel like
being present is being in your body out
of your mind
do i'm saying and so it was like i just
wasn't thinking
i was just there what was it like having
to audition
for the film do you remember what you
had to do for the audition allen
oh maybe
well i first got the roll
i faced i not face recorded
but like recorded on video
um yeah i recorded on video
then facetimed after facetiming i
actually went to plan b bro and
did my lunch did your mom help you learn
your lines
yeah she was the only one with me
in the in the
well tulsa oklahoma which is where we
filmed
but my yeah
yeah what was your mom's reaction when
she saw you
on screen in the film for the first time
once the whole film was finished
oh that's really easy
she cried i thought she might have
oh my god he cried oh mama
he's like
[Laughter]
um just thinking back to to when you
were filming
and those lovely lovely days on set was
there one
scene that you loved doing the most
well honestly to me i
probably liked the p scene where i give
p
to the grandma that was really fun it's
a classic
it's great it's very funny i also loved
your cowboy boots in the film did you
get to keep those
well i didn't get to keep that real pair
but i got to keep the
and i said the um
extra pair
and did any of the other cast give you
any good tips of how to act that you
remember still
probably
[Music]
don't rush and
[Music]
just be yourself and i'm not sure if
this was
actually one but um try to
blend in kind of mm-hmm
yes um we have a question
from the audience um for you from
isabella
who's asked what was the best thing in
general about filming manari
what was the best thing about filming
minari
yeah mostly everything everything
brilliant we are going i'm going to go
to clark next and then we'll come back
to you in a bit is that okay
okay okay oh that was
just priceless how can i follow that
i want to talk to you about spike lee
because what a phenomenal guy he's such
an
energetic director but he also knows how
to
inject gravitas and depth into those
scenes
what was it like working with him and
how does he get the best out of you
i think that uh for most directors um
90 percent of their job is in the
casting
and i think that he cast this very very
well
we are all men of a certain age and a
certain experience
of politics in america we've all come up
through that time of
the vietnam war he allowed us to free
associate he allowed us to improvise
there were times when when your heart
got so full uh there were things that
you just you just can't put these
moments into words and put them onto a
script
um one of the scenes was
when paul when delroy begins to lose it
on the boat
you know now um
that was a really long scene but you i i
hope that at some point in time in the
future there is the director's cut of
that
because there were scenes that were
like that uh like the one i'm
referencing where
it became very physical you know um
deroy was losing it you know and i had
to hold him
back you know and
we were all over the boat we were
falling all over the boat
and we were just going for it you know
and
somewhere in the back of your head
you're hoping someone will say cut
but the other side of it is that you're
hoping someone doesn't because
where this moment has taken you is
someplace magical
um paul i want to talk to you about
being on your set and
the the sound design specifically it is
just one of the most fascinating things
and especially in the film the
communication is done through so many
different forms
can you tell me a little bit about how
the sound design was taken i know that
you know i think rizz was saying that
there was a microphone
in his mouth on his chest and all this
so tell me about how all that was taken
on set
well i i had no idea that it was that
darius was going to spend more time in
the sound design
after the rap of this film then he did
actually filming
wow i mean i didn't know that so it's
actually another character in the movie
but um so i we were i was just doing my
job as we move forward working with the
deaf community in that deaf sober house
and just focusing on that i wasn't
thinking about the sound at all
i was shocked when i saw the film uh we
saw it in toronto my wife who my wife
has no hearing in her left ear and has
about 30 percent
in her right ear so i'm sitting on her
right side here
and we're watching the film and um she
said she's
tears are coming out of her eye she says
oh my god that's how it sounds for me
that's what it sounds like for me
and i've suffered uh tinnitus in my
ring in my ears from the the flight deck
i worked on in vietnam i was on an
aircraft carrier i worked on i was a
hospital corpsman
on the flight deck and that that sounded
that ee that he goes through
i've got that in my right ear plus
playing in a heavy metal band for years
and years
and not having any ear protection until
the 1980s
that's when it was invented so that's a
very real thing
all the guys that i worked with on that
flight deck
that are my age right now have lost
their hearing
hearing loss is the number one ailment
of
all veterans of all wars all the way
back to the civil war
for very obvious reasons so it's a it's
a
a hidden disability you don't have you
can't see it
and yet there are the deaf community is
such a
it's not a monolith it's people have
profound hearing loss
like my father people that were are
deafened like my mother at the age of
five
who could still have the ability to
speak and then it's taken away
people that all the way down to the
level of joe who
loses it at a much later age and speaks
normally
without an accent or anything of
deafness and yet
doesn't live in deaf culture lives in
the hearing world that
that he has no foothold in because you
know
nobody can be bothered what did he just
say i'll tell you later why are they
laughing ah you wouldn't i'll tell you
later
it's not important that's a classic line
deaf people get
it's too much it's too much trouble to
include you
to be inclusionary instead of uh
just being excluded from from pop
culture as my parents were
so i wasn't aware of the sound design
until i saw the movie
i was just living in this deaf community
that i've lived in my whole life
you know um daniel there are some
scenes in judaism the black messiah
where i sort of i don't know i maybe i'm
probably projecting here but i imagined
you having some sort of out of body
experience because they are just
so kind of powerful and on such a huge
scale how did you stay present
during those sorts of scenes when you're
you know chairman fred is at his
kind of most like you know being his
being like the orator the incredible
orator that he was
it's like i started acting doing
improvisation
yeah i used to have this saying when i
was doing improv
he said when you're in your head you're
dead you know
so i feel like being present is being in
your body
out of your mind do you understand and
so
it was like i just wasn't thinking i was
just there
i was just there and like things were
coming through me
things just coming from because certain
scenes were saying his actual words
verbatim
and then the whole setup is 450 people
in a location similar i'm dressed like
him the whole scenario is there for him
and for that spirit to come out you know
it's like you're doing a ritual and you
just have to be there
you know i mean i do all the prep and
then i have to forget all the work i've
done
then i just have to trust and just be
there and that's like just being in your
body
you know and that's that's kind of what
it was so a lot of the takes i don't
really remember the takes i'm usually
the kind of person
oh yeah that was that date they used
that one and this one oh yeah they used
that one
but then all that i was just i was just
there
and i was just present you know i mean
and and and um
and yeah yeah but that but and it's hard
because sometimes because you're doing
those speeches
and you're doing i mean it's unnatural
the length of time you're doing those
speeches on set you're doing it for 12
hours as
speech givers aren't doing those
speeches your voice is going
so it's like you're you're you're to go
get all you
if you're doing a scene you're just
doing the take just before lunch you're
getting hungry so you're getting tired
because you're just hungry just doing
speeches physically you're just hungry
so those moments that you get and then
it stumbles you that's because your body
your mind is going yo we need we need
something i want something
i want something in order to be present
and then so that's that's what it was
for me was kind of like um
i really uh i really understood just
kind of like just letting go
just letting go and accepting it coming
through and um
and i don't really there's i don't think
there's words to really capture that
you know it's been something to be
experienced not to be articulated
you